hey guys it's kristin roshan valentine's
Day is right around the corner that's
why I've teamed up with wire to show you
what's new and what's hot when shopping
for the ladies so let's go every woman
likes to be on the cutting edge of
technology especially when it's stylish
and chic and the iphone 6s is definitely
it it's a supercomputer it's a super
smart phone great camera and then all of
your social media right there in a neat
little package plus did I mention it's
pretty stylish to buying jewelry for
valentine's Day is never easy but
Pandora makes it a little bit easier
pandora is all about mixing and matching
with the perfect terms to allow the
woman in your life the chance to
showcase her individual style now that's
a smart Valentine's Day gift a good pair
of headphones make all the difference in
the world and these master and dynamic
headphones don't just look good they
make whatever you're listening to sounds
amazing these headphones are for the
girl that loves to rock out while
looking good doing it just for the
record these are coming with me thanks
guys those are my picks shop heart stay
wired and have a happy Valentine's Day